[Music]
on this Monday night making a deal the
tentative agreement ending the strike
for more than a hundred and twenty
thousand public servants I believe it
will be accepted by the membership and
which workers are still off the job
dropping the Writ and the gloves the
ndp's failed economic policies you also
know Danielle Smith and she will do
whatever she wants Alberta's election
campaign officially kicks off the
writings to watch for running out of
time and ways to escape Sudan what
stranded Canadians are being urged to do
and coronation countdown London's
excitement for a once in a lifetime
event
global national with Donna friezen
reporting tonight for a Nasser
good evening to you thanks for joining
us we begin with some good news on this
may day most of the federal public
workers who are on strike over the last
12 days are now back at work the public
service Alliance of Canada reached a
tentative deal with the government
overnight Mackenzie gray on the deal
that ended one of the largest strikes in
Canadian history
after a 12-day strike relief from the
treasury board president well let's say
that my kids were very happy that I will
be able to spend time with them Mona
forte in the public service Alliance of
Canada able to reach a tentative deal
early this morning increasing wages for
120 000 public servants by 12 percent
over four years we've reached fair and
competitive deal for employees
but that agreement comes up well short
of the Union's ask of a 13.5 percent
bump over three years we think this is a
good deal we think it's the best we
could have gotten even if we leave the
members out for another you know three
or four days the union pointing to a
one-time payout of 2500 per employee to
help make up the difference in the lower
salary offer but it also helps public
servants who missed out on nearly two
weeks pay employers typically are
allowed to do a deal after a strike that
essentially justifies the employees
having gone off and sees them made whole
at the end of the day psac also unable
to enshrine the right to work from home
in the Collective Agreement their other
major priority instead compromising to
have the liberal policy of working at
home three days a week reviewed on an
employee by employee basis which could
be a win-win for both sides not only
does that say it costs for the treasury
board but also it will save costs for
the psac because they're not going to be
incurring costs of going to labor
arbitration either
The Next Step putting the tentative
agreement to a vote with the members I'm
not going to try to predict or determine
what the members uh may vote but I I
believe it's a good deal and I believe
it will be accepted by the membership
cutting a deal with PSI doesn't mean the
end of the labor strike for the federal
government Farah there are still 35 000
CRI employees walking the picket line
so so McKenzie let's talk about that why
don't the CRA workers have a deal today
well their key point of sticking is
Wages between the union and the federal
government the CRA employees are asking
for nearly 30 percent over three years
because they say they're some of the
lowest paid civil servants compared to
other departments now that 30 asked is
well above what psac just got and what
the CRA offer is from the federal
government which is nine percent over
three years now those workers are on the
picket line as I mentioned which means
anyone trying to get a hold of the CRA
on tax deadline day of all days is gonna
have a tough time and what does that
mean for your tax returns well if you
file online the CRA says there shouldn't
be any kind of delay but if you file by
paper there could be some issues in
getting your money back and again if you
owe money there could be a penalty if
you don't pay today Farah since the
federal government declined to extend
the deadline to file your taxes despite
the strike a good reminder Mackenzie
gray in Ottawa thank you Mackenzie
out of controlled wildfires growing in
size have pushed people in two Alberta
communities out of their homes
evacuation orders have been issued for
residents in Entwistle and Evansburg
roughly 100 kilometers west of Edmonton
the Flames have decimated about 2500
hectares fueled by warm spring weather
dry conditions and strong winds high
temperatures are in the forecast all
week and in BC about 40 fires are
burning across the province with two of
those sparked within the past day
Alberta's provincial election campaign
officially kicked off today it's a race
that will see former Premier Rachel
notley trying to regain power from
Danielle Smith the UCP leader who took
over from Jason Kenney last fall now
polls are showing the two parties are
neck and neck with analysts expecting a
hard-fought race that could come down to
trust as Heather York's West explains
for the next four weeks all eyes will be
on Battleground Calgary
and they're off with a fixed election 28
days away May 1st marks the official
dropping of the Writ in Alberta and the
beginning of what is shaping up to be a
very tight race I don't pride myself on
having a crystal ball but I do think
it's going to be close and and I think
it's it's close in narrative you have
two parties that are making a very
different case for Alberta and so
there's a stark difference there and
that Stark difference is registering
very starkly in the polling evenly split
Alberta enters this election with the
UCP holding 60 of a possible 87 seats
the NDP has 23. if the NDP hopes to form
government it will need to pick up 21
additional writings and while they may
be able to gain ground in a couple of
smaller centers like Lethbridge and
Banff most of the races to watch will be
in Calgary that's 26 ridings that will
likely see the heaviest campaigning
leading up to election day but across
the city voter concerns vary widely take
for instance the city's Northeast a
culturally diverse area that has been
through a lot the last four years in
this part of the city
most of the people are the front line
workers how do you think what happened
during covet here will impact the
outcome of this election Premier Jason
Kenney on my show spoke about that the
cultural ties the cultural background of
these people has played a role in
spreading the virus that was somewhat
offensive to these people people still
feel offended that this is one of the
issues they haven't forgotten it both
parties kicked off their campaigns in
Calgary making promises but getting
those Jabs in too well Rachel notley and
the NDP were in government
they hide taxes and fees 97 times my
opponent in this race Daniel Smith she
kind of wears her flip-flops like
they're going out of style each hoping
to convince albertans they're the leader
worthy of the most trust with voting day
just four weeks away Heather urich's
West Global News Calgary
there are reports two Canadian volunteer
Fighters have been killed in eastern
Ukraine they apparently died on the
front lines in the fiercely contested
city of late last week
in a statement Global Affairs Canada
says it is aware of reports of the death
of two Canadian citizens in Ukraine and
we are following up with authorities for
more information our thoughts are with
the family and friends of the deceased
the United Nations world food program
has resumed operations in Sudan it
halted operations two weeks ago after
three employees were killed in the
conflict but the situation on the ground
is still very dangerous and Canadians
trapped in the country are desperate to
find a way out after the last military
flights departed over the weekend Global
Affairs is urging people to make the
perilous Journey to the port of Sudan
but as Korea Israel reports Canadians
who arrive there say help is hard to
come by thousands of people are flooding
into the port of Sudan and seeking ships
Bound for a safer place now one of the
only ways out of the conflict-ravaged
country
suha Osman is from Ottawa she and her
family are stuck at a hotel that's
become a hub for the displaced the buses
keep coming in from madini from from
soba so many different places of people
and now they've flooded like the front
entrance of this entire Hotel because
they're not being let in around 400
Canadians were flown out of Sudan on
military planes and Allied aircraft last
week foreign affairs minister Melanie
Jolie traveled to Kenya and met with
some of them for the Canadians still in
Sudan options are limited the Canadian
Forces has suspended air evacuations the
Department of Defense has moved to small
reconnaissance team to the port but
would not say whether Canadian Consular
officials are there the situation when
it comes to further evacuations for
example is what I think you're getting
at will depend entirely on the
logistical ability to uh to succeed at
this overflowing Hotel there are U.S and
British flags but Osman says there are
no signs of the Canadian government is
it so shocking but there's absolutely no
Canadian officially raneem Ibrahim lives
in London Ontario her family is also
trapped at the Port yeah it's really bad
her relatives made the dangerous Journey
from Khartoum there's like dead bodies
everywhere in on streets and like even
you can't stay there because this it
smells so bad
a power struggle between military
factions plunged the country into chaos
and is leaving millions of people at
risk of starvation approximately a third
of the country's population already in
need of humanitarian assistance and
since the start of violence on the 15th
of April
that has gotten a lot worse while the
American government is getting its
citizens out on Navy ships it's not
clear what the exit strategy is for
stranded Canadians the Department of
Defense says there are two Canadian
vessels that are in quote close vicinity
to the port and are prepared for direct
support as our allies develop options
pharah churia Israeli and Ottawa thank
you for that Korea to the United States
now where Wall Street giant JP Morgan
Chase has taken over First Republic Bank
completing what is now the second
largest bank failure in U.S history the
troubled First Republic had been under
pressure since last month after the
collapse of two other U.S lenders
Regulators are hoping today's deal will
quell fears within the industry but as
Ann gaviola reports the turmoil has
fueled calls for more oversight on
America's biggest banks
after weeks of trouble U.S Regulators
seized first Republic's assets this is
not the end okay I don't think we're
going to get three and done crises don't
sort of end this easily there will be
other issues out there in the banking
world the San francisco-based bank now
the third to fail in the U.S in two
months first Republic's assets were
promptly sold to JPMorgan Chase
America's biggest bank all of these sort
of halter Skelter Moves Like These
midnight deals and Marathon sessions
over the weekend are trying to uh
firewall the banking system and prevent
it from becoming systemic customers saw
84 branches across eight states reopen
Monday under the JP Morgan Banner after
Regulators worked all weekend to get the
deal done this is now the second largest
bank failure in U.S history well
depositors are being protected
shareholders are losing their
Investments and critically taxpayers are
not the ones that are on the hook First
Republic the victim of rising interest
rates in a crisis of confidence much
like Silicon Valley Bank a financial
autopsy of svb on Friday blamed poor
management and watered-down regulation
saying the industry needs stricter
policing to prevent future failures the
banking industry during the Trump years
lobbied the Trump Administration to
water down the regulations imposed after
2008-9 and I think that was a mistake
first Republic's failure isn't expected
to stop the American Central Bank from
going ahead with a rate hike on
Wednesday economists say weaker U.S
growth will weigh on Canadian exports
the good news is that deposit outflows
that we saw at First Republic were a
hundred billion dollars worth of
deposits were pulled out in the first
quarter of this year aren't happening at
other U.S banks but that doesn't mean
we're out of the woods just yet pharah
and gaviola thank you for that
demonstrators around the world took part
in Mayday protests for workers rights
today in France anger was focused on the
country's unpopular decision to raise
the retirement age from 62 to 64.
[Applause]
protesters lit e-bikes on fire and
police fired tear gas into the crowds
French president Emmanuel macron says
the pension reforms are necessary as the
population ages but critics say the
changes are an attack on workers rights
Mayday also known as Labor Day is
traditionally celebrated on May 1st to
honor workers around the world
a Manhunt for an accused mass murderer
in Texas coming up where police are
searching now and the controversial
comments from the state's governor
to Texas now where police are closing in
on a man matching the description of a
suspect accused of killing his five
neighbors execution Style on Friday
night today officials revealed that
suspect Mexican national Francisco
oropeza was actually in the U.S
illegally and had been previously
deported several times in fact Jackson
prosco on the mass tragedy and the
search for the Killer
with few firm leads police widened their
search for the suspected gunman scouring
a rural County near Houston after a
possible sighting 38-year-old Francisco
oropeza is considered armed and
dangerous there's always a danger when
you've got a guy that's just shot five
people in the head execution style those
five victims were the suspect's
neighbors killed Friday night after they
asked oropeza to stop firing a gun in
his yard because it was disturbing their
sleeping baby instead he allegedly
walked next door and opened fire
Sunday the small community of Cleveland
Texas held a vigil for the youngest
victim a boy killed alongside his mother
I don't have words to describe what
happened said the boy's father Wilson
Garcia who had originally asked the
gunman to stop shooting
tragedy has been compounded by Politics
the suspect is a Mexican national who
had reportedly been deported from the
U.S at least four previous times while
Texas governor Greg Abbott tweeted that
the victims were all illegal immigrants
though their status was unclear my heart
is with
this eight-year-old little boy
I don't I don't care if he was here
legally I don't care if he was here
illegally police have issued an eighty
thousand dollar reward for the arrest of
oropesa they believe he may have called
a friend for help in escaping as the
search for the suspect continues so does
the search for answers
Jackson prosco Global News
[Music]
simplifying the system ahead the calls
for Canada to create a universal Mental
Health Care Program
mental health is critical to a person's
overall well-being but getting access to
support can be harder than you think as
the demand for mental health services
increase so do wait lists and cost is
another factor that puts help Out Of
Reach for most Canadians tonight
Catherine Ward looks at the calls for a
universal Mental Health Care system
Canadians are really proud of our
Universal Health Care system and yet
mental health Falls outside of that
system a system Margaret Eaton with the
Canadian Mental Health Association says
needs an overhaul 69 percent of people
living in Canada believe are in a mental
health crisis but 82 percent believe
that governments have not responded to
do enough about that Mental Health
crisis a new survey conducted by the
CMHA found 87 percent of people living
in Canada want Universal Mental Health
Care data suggests out of the 35 percent
of Canadians who said they had a mental
health concern in the past year
one-third did not seek help some reasons
were because of cost and not knowing
where to go experts say if you don't
have an employer plan or live in a major
urban center accessing support is more
challenging and access to existing
programs isn't equal while some programs
are free you'll find the waiting lists
are incredibly long like those free
programs for children where you have to
wait a year and a half but the reality
is only about one-third of those
children actually get the services they
need to help them recover underpinning
this data is the compounding effect of
the covid-19 pandemic when we compared
their mental health from before the
pandemic to during the pandemic we saw a
notable increase in their depression
symptoms and a slight increase in their
anxiety symptoms Sherry Madigan led a
review of data on Mental Health impacts
of the pandemic she says mental health
challenges were more often found in
girls and youth from higher income
backgrounds Madigan believes that stems
from abrupt halt to extracurricular
activities and greater access to
technology plus girls being more open to
discussing their feelings whenever
children experienced a mental health
difficulty in childhood this places them
at greater risk of experiencing mental
difficulties in adulthood so we may see
a trickle effect for generations to come
Catherine Ward Global News Toronto
Toronto Maple Leaf fans hoping to watch
the second round of playoff games in
Florida can't buy their tickets just yet
that's because for the first 24 hours of
sales tickets for games three and four
against the Panthers have been
restricted to American residents
Ticketmaster says residency will be
based on credit card billing addresses
and early orders by non-us residents
will be canceled and refunded the
Panthers say they wanted to give local
fans first access game one of the series
is tomorrow night in Toronto
[Music]
Monumental moment next the preparation
and anticipation for King Charles's
coronation
[Music]
global national with Donna Friesen
winner of the 2023 Canadian screen Award
for best national news anchor and best
national newscast
excitement is building in London for the
coronation of King Charles III this
Saturday and as we get closer to the big
day new details are being shared Europe
bureau chief krystalgamansing has more
on how the first coronation of a British
monarch in 70 years will be both unique
and steeped in Tradition
right now it's all about the
preparations but the pageantry is coming
I think it's just a historical
significance so we came out just to have
a look and see what people are doing out
here we do look at the
look at the news and the crown on
this office
there is always crowd around Buckingham
Palace but with the coronation just a
few days away obviously a lot of people
are here just to check things out as for
those who are taking part in the
coronation day procession while they are
taking advantage of every minute to get
in rehearsals
[Music]
over the weekend hundreds of members of
the household division polish their
performance skills also in Hampshire
troops from the UK and the Commonwealth
focused on their form on a quiet Air
Base more than six thousand members of
the Armed Forces will be involved in the
coronation and what the world watching
no one wants a misstep
[Music]
Queen Elizabeth's coronation 70 years
ago was groundbreaking it was televised
history will also be made May 6th for
the first time female Bishops will
participate in the coronation the king
will pray aloud reflecting the duty and
privilege he has to serve all
communities and the homage of peers has
been replaced by an homage of the people
but asking the public to swear their
allegiance is causing a stir that is
exactly what happens at a citizenship
sorry you swear allegiance to your
Monarch I mean we are a monarchy whether
you like it or not we are a monarchy and
this is the sort of thing that happens
at every citizenship ceremony so it
didn't strike me as odd until I heard
all the fuss for the coronation no one
will be watching to see if it said and
it will be a personal choice many people
even some taking in the sights along the
mouth say the Royals don't have an
impact on their daily lives but they
like the pageantry and being a part of
History
Crystal gomancing Global News London
and Global News will have special
coverage off the king's coronation on
Saturday our Donna Friesen will be live
in London at 5 a.m Eastern and 2 A.M
Pacific right here on global
and that's global national for this
Monday night I'm Farah Nasser on behalf
of our whole crew here we want to thank
you so much for spending part of your
evening with us tonight's your Canada is
Merit British Columbia we love seeing
your Canada so please keep emailing us
your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com until tomorrow take
care of yourselves and take care of each
other good night
[Music]
thank you